first of all let me start with
congratulations and I mean that really
sincerely you guys did such a great job
I'm sure you're hearing that from
everyone who's coming in but I just want
to add to the chorus thank you
um so obviously these were roles that a
lot of people wanted and I'm just
curious ultimately what did you pay to
be in the movie I did about a million
and a half I think I paid Rob personally
yeah yeah yep you yeah I think that's a
similar amount paid a lot to to be in it
yeah I'm broke now my life savings
this is one of those films that everyone
grew up with and that I would imagine
that you you know you put a lot of
pressure on yourself to do these
characters right and to to deliver the
best performance you can but what was
there a day that you were filming
something that you felt you put extra
pressure on yourself like oh my God this
is a moment that's going to be like
forever you know yeah I mean I think for
me that day would have been uh the part
of your world see sequence of the three
days of filming because it was
definitely such a song that's been
imprinted on all of our hearts for such
a long time and I felt like this duty to
make it my own but also live up to the
original that Jody Benson did such
beautifully and I was so Overjoyed that
in at the end of those three days I feel
like I really was able to capture the
essence of Ariel and that desperateness
and that plea for help that she was
crying out for in that song and I'm
ultimately so happy with the ending
result yeah actually it was my song too
that felt really frightening I think you
want to do justice to the amazing song
that they had written that Alan and Lynn
had done and
bringing a song to life for the first
time you know God this can't mess this
up I need to do this justice so yeah I
think both from a musical point of view
I really wanted to do it well and it
felt like a lot of pressure and also
just the filming it as well
um it was uh we were doing it in
Sardinia and then we came and we did uh
the end part of it in Pinewood so it
just felt like quite a big epic sequence
and we just wanted to get it right I can
tell you that you did it right and I'll
say why because I see a lot of press
screenings and they know that for the
press and I rarely if ever hear people
clapping during a movie uh at a press
screening and it happened a few times
while watching this thank you so oh I
didn't clap I mean I didn't think
I'm joking
um uh one of the things though I think
that people will not realize were the
technical challenges of filming
underwater but you're obviously not
underwater so can you sort of talk to
people who might not understand the
filmmaking aspect of what it was
actually like filming those underwater
sequences yes well filming the moving
the water sequences like you said were
technically really challenging but so
exciting for me to play and do
I learned a lot about stunt work and
being in harnesses and suspended in the
air and having to stimulate a swimming
motion while you're on a blue screen in
the middle of the air and being scared
of heights like Jonah was and trying not
to think about how high up you were in
the air it was like all of those
emotions and feelings but ultimately in
the end seeing the result was like wow
it really does look like we're in water
and it paid off yeah I'm also blown away
by the CGI in the film it really looks
like Rob took a camera and just put it
under water it was um so I have to ask
you what do you have a favorite sequence
from the original movie and I'm curious
what your favorite sequence is in this
movie doesn't have to be something you
were in just right off the bat in this
movie I think Under the Sea as a
sequence especially from the CGI point
of view so insane like it's so beautiful
it feels very referential to a lot of
Disney films of the past like Fantasia
it's just such a colorful beautiful
spectacle with you right in the middle
of it and it feels really exciting and
and from the cartoon
I loved Kiss the Girl it feels like a
really magical moment in the film and so
nice and and also a great dramatic
moment because you're willing to mind
you're hoping they're going to kiss and
it doesn't happen and all around them
that amazing song so yeah I'd agree with
Jonah under the sea is so cool to see it
all come together the VFX and CGI I mean
because when we were filming that you
don't see all of that around you you
just know it's going to be painted on
after and then a new song Wild uncharted
waters that Jonah did is incredible and
I think audiences are gonna absolutely
love it because it's showing a deeper
side of Prince Eric and internally how
he feels and and why the way he is going
after the things he wants the way he is
so it's incredible I think that is also
one of my favorite new sequences in the
film on that note I need to go I'm just
going to say congrats and I'm pretty
confident the movie's gonna make some
money